-Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually when I --
I got new boots.
I'm wearing new boots today.
-What happened?
-I feel good.
I feel good with these boots.
-What are they? Let's see them.
-Shready?
-Shready? Yeah.
-Get shready for this.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow!
Damn, gee!
♪♪
Wow, that's like "Yellowstone."
-Yeah, it's like "Yellowstone."
I was thinking about even maybe
just tucking my pants
in the boots.
-Oh yeah, blouse them
like a paratrooper.
♪♪
-At least I can see
how cool they are.
-Yeah, that looks totally cool.
-It does?
-Yeah. Oh, sure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Well, well, well!
-Got them on my desk.
-Yeah, man.
-Like "Dukes of Hazzard."
-Yeah, like "Fifth Element"
boots -- You --
-You know what today is?
-What is it today?
-Friday, and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox, return emails,
and of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
-Oh.
-And I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
James -- James, can I get
some thank-you note
writing music, please?
Oh, my gosh, it's Batman.
-Oh, my gosh.
He loves Batman. Yeah.
-It's Batman.
[ Laughter ]
-That was crazy.
I don't know
what happened to him.
-I don't understand.
-He went off the rails.
♪♪
-Thank you, Mardi Gras,
St. Patrick's Day,
and Spring Break
for proving that
whoever planned out March
really liked to party.
Yeah. Oww!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, President Biden's
State of the Union address,
for being a great thing to watch
if you're an American
and a terrible thing
if you own a clapper.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's like a strobe light.
-"My lights keep going
on and off!"
Oh, no, I'm having a seizure.
-Clap for 60 minutes. Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, Colin Farrell
as The Penguin,
for being the ultimate
Tinder bio photo
versus who actually shows up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Quacks ]
♪♪
Thank you, shamrock McFlurry,
for sounding like a fake name
Bono uses to check in
to a hotel.
Shamrock McFlurry?
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Ash Wednesday,
for making everyone look like
they panicked at Sephora.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Okay, all right.
I'll be right there,
yeah, yeah."
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Thank you, bag of baby carrots.
I don't know what's going on
in there,
but there's no way
you should be that wet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What happened?
-Gross.
-Gross. I love baby carrots.
-Gross. Gross.
-I don't like the wet.
-Yeah, it's gross.
-Wet carrot.
♪♪
-Thank you, Genius Bar,
for not going by
your original longer name,
"What moronic thing did you
do to your phone
this time genius bar."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
first signs of spring,
or as I like to call you,
Earth stubble.
There you have it, everybody,
those are our thank-you notes.